es ist der seltsamsten planet des
universums der bisher gefunden wurde
diese exoplaneten ist wirklich äußerst
äußerst merkwürdig wars 121 b ist nicht
nur so super super heißt er hat auch
eine äußerst kuriose form er sieht
nämlich aus wie ein american football
und noch etwas lässt astronomie teams
weltweit staunen der exoplaneten metalle
ins all
dort gibt es einen gas total verrückt
klicks um science-fiction gibt's täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
der exoplanet trägt die katalognummer
wasp 121 b und umkreist einen stern im
sternbild achterdeck am südhimmel liegt
rund 900 lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt und hat drei mal soviel masse
wie jupiter und der ist ja der größte
planet in unserem sonnensystem us army
teams konnten boss 221b bereits vor vier
jahren 2015 aufspüren und eine wirkliche
besonderheit beobachten der exoplaneten
ist nämlich äußerst kurios geformt weil
er seinen heimatstern so eng umkreist
wird er von dessen gravitation fast
zerrissen aber eben nur fast seine form
jedenfalls wird extrem in die länge
gestreckt und die ähnlichkeit zu einem
american football lässt sich nicht
abstreiten doch das was das us
forschungsteam jetzt nachweisen konnte
ist eine echte premiere mit hilfe des
hubble-weltraumteleskops konnten die
fachleute nämlich beobachten dass der
exoplanet metalle ins weltall schleudert
konkret konnten mit dem space telescope
imaging spectrograph wolken von eisen
und magnesium gas um boss 121 beobachtet
werden die analysen zeigen dass die
obere atmosphäre des exoplaneten auf
unglaubliche 2500 grad celsius
aufgeheizt wird bedingt durch seine nähe
zum stern
solch eine hohe temperatur konnte
bislang auf keinem anderen bekannten
exoplaneten nachgewiesen werden boß 221b
wird in der fachsprache auch als
sogenannter hot jupiter bezeichnet damit
sind glas planeten gemeint deren masse
ähnlich zu der des jupiters ist oder
sogar größer und auf deren oberfläche
ist zu
sehr heiß ist diese extrem hohe
temperatur erklärt auch warum metalle
wie magnesium oder eisen als gas ins all
geschleudert werden und nicht in der
atmosphäre kondensieren auf diesem
exoplaneten ist es also tatsächlich so
heiß dass sogar eisen verdampft und in
den weltraum verschwindet magnesium und
eisen kommen mir also in gasförmiger
form vor und steigen in die obere
atmosphäre auf dort entweichen sie dann
ins all
zusammen mit helium und wasserstoff
bislang kannten fachleute solche metall
das auch von anderen planeten allerdings
nur innerhalb der atmosphäre eine
absolut spannende entdeckung also dazu
david singh der an der studie beteiligt
war
schwermetalle wurden bereits auf anderen
hot jupiter gesehen aber nur in der
unteren atmosphäre also weiß man nicht
ob sie entweichen oder nicht bei vox
221b haben der magnesium und eisen das
so weit weg von dem planeten beobachtet
dass sie nicht mehr durch schwerkraft
gebunden sind
in zukunft soll diese außergewöhnliche
exponate auch mit dem james webb
weltraumteleskop beobachtet werden so
erhoffen sich forschungsteams weltweit
das dann eine detaillierte analyse aller
chemischen elemente möglich wird diese
erkenntnisse
die könnten eine große hilfe dabei seien
die bildung solcher hot jupiter und
planetensysteme im allgemeinen besser zu
verstehen biomarker für exoplaneten wie
finden wir eigentlich exo planeten auf
denen das leben gibt super spannendes
thema von über raum tv anklicken
anschauen und hyperraum tv abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran